GABRIELLE DE JASAY
- Ici à Durbuy, on se retrousse
les manches pour tout nettoyer.
Je me trouve ici, là où
la rivière a tellement
été gonflée par les pluies
diluviennes qu'elle est sortie
de son lit. Elle a envahi la
ville et elle s'est engouffrée
comme un torrent dans la rue,
jusqu'à 1,80 mètre de hauteur,
forçant les habitants
à se réfugier au 1er étage
de leur maison, parfois
jusqu'à 36 heures d'affilée
sans nourriture, sans eau
potable, sans électricité.
Dans le centre historique
de la ville aussi, qui est
beaucoup plus touristique,
on s'active avec énergie.
On nettoie, au déblaye, on vide,
parce que l'enjeu, c'est
de rouvrir au plus vite,
au plus fort de la saison
touristique. Les restaurateurs,
les commerçants, les hôteliers
travaillent d'arrache-pied.
Comme qu'Igor, ce jeune hôtelier
que nous avons rencontré un peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui, écoutez.
IGOR COMPERE, hôtelier à Durbuy
- Pour le moment, la priorité
est de déblayer tout afin de
voir tout au clair et nettoyer
un maximum pour essayer de
rouvrir pour lundi. Parce que
les 15 jours qui sont ici, pour
le moment, c'est les 15 plus
gros jours de l'année, donc..
On attend les assurances pour
prendre des photos, savoir ce
qu'on peut jeter, pas jeter,
garder, essayer de ranger au
maximum. Puis on essaie de faire
un état des lieux aussi, savoir
ce qui fonctionne, ce qu'on doit
racheter, les frigos, un peu
tout, savoir ce que le sinistre
a cassé, et voilà.
- L'Allemagne est bien sûr
le pays le plus touché.
Et on redoute que le bilan
humain ne s'alourdisse encore
puisque des dizaines de
personnes sont toujours portées
disparues. On craint aussi
les glissements de terrain,
comme celui qui s'est produit
dans la commune d'Erftstadt, où
toute une partie de la commune
a tout simplement disparu,
a été engloutie.
Les régions les plus touchées
sont la Rhénanie-Palatinat et
la Rhénanie-du-Nord-Westphalie,
où 19 000 secouristes
ont été déployés.
Le quotidien allemand
le plus lu, le quotidien Bild,
a titré sur les "inondations de
la mort". Et c'est sans conteste
la catastrophe naturelle
la plus grave qu'ait connue
l'Allemagne depuis au moins
une cinquantaine d'années.
Ici Gabrielle de Jasay, Radio-
Canada, Durbuy, en Belgique.